presión en torno a 20.000 armas fantasma
halladas en eeuu en 2021 cuyas partes
son imposibles de rastrear en la escena
de un crimen hasta ahora porque el
presidente joe biden anunció un nuevo
paquete normativo para elevar el control
de estas y otras armas en eeuu
un delincuente un terrorista un abusador
doméstico puede pasar de un kit de armas
a un arma en tan solo 30 minutos los
compradores no están obligados a pasar
verificaciones de antecedentes porque
las armas no tienen número de serie
desde que la ley se haga efectiva la
justicia perseguirá la fabricación de
estos kits de piezas sin un número de
serie una medida que no ha sido fácil de
alcanzar por la fuerza de los lobbies
armamentísticos
el lobby de las armas trató de atar a
los reguladores y al papeleo durante
mucho tiempo mucho tiempo la asociación
nacional del rifle denominó esta regla
como extrema extrema pero déjenme
preguntarles es extremo proteger a los
oficiales de policía es extremo proteger
a nuestros hijos las autoridades
policiales han alerta sobre el aumento
exponencial de este tipo de armas en
eeuu armas que han sido usadas en
algunas de las más sonadas masacres en
el país mi atleta superviviente del
tiroteo de la escuela secundaria shows
en 2019 estuvo en el acto para dar fe de
ello la medida entra en vigor en 120
días y desde ya hay organizaciones que
anunciaron que la van a demandar